journey is now with more is Trump
campaigns national press secretary Hogan
Gidley Hogan's thank you so much for
joining us here tonight I want to talk
about Joe Biden plagiarism but I really
need to get your reaction to what the
President did in commuting Roger stones
sentenced today what's your reaction to
that what's the president's view on this
well it's a good move by the president
of course listen so many people so many
good people were caught up in this
Russian hoax this was perpetrated by
overzealous Democrats partisan hacks
trying to take down a president we now
know the campaign was spied upon
wiretapped authorized by the previous
administration we wouldn't know if
Donald Trump hadn't been elected that
come--and clapper and Bennett were
Brennan were all lying in front of
Congress and in other ways we wouldn't
know the names
Lisa Paige and Peter struck the two
lovers that conspired to take down a
president with an insurance policy
we wouldn't know any of that had Donald
Trump not been elected now we do and I
think the president's doing the right
thing by trying to right some of the
wrongs of the partisanship of the past
no I think you're absolutely right
imagine if Hillary Clinton won that the
likes of Comey and mccabe and struck and
although they would be running the
country of the law enforcement end of
this so thank goodness that that that
didn't come to fruition the president is
making a very very strong accusation
accuse anybody of plagiarism but it's
not new for Joe Biden he's been in this
boat many many times throughout his
decades of service oh absolutely
we know look he plagiarized a couple of
words from the president's past but he's
plagiarizing the policies from
socialists like Bernie Sanders an AOC an
ill hano Mar Rasheeda to leave Elizabeth
Warren his policies are going to be so
detrimental to this country but let's be
clear we don't have to guess what a
Biden economy looks like we just lived
through it for the past eight years
850,000 jobs lost just from NAFTA alone
70,000 manufacturing plants closed
millions of jobs lost because of his
relationship with China because of his
defense of China we also don't have to
guess how our cities and streets would
look if Joe Biden were president we saw
rioters
and looters drag innocent Americans just
trying to defend their businesses out
into the streets beat them within an
inch of their lives left to lie in a
pool of their own blood Joe Biden said
nothing when churches were burned when
stores were looted riots across our city
streets he said nothing about that so
you don't have to guess what would
happen in this country we've already
seen it happen
Hogan Gidley thank you so much for
joining us tonight we do appreciate it
absolutely Jason if I may say one more
thing just because of Joe Biden's record
of the past not defending the American
worker gutting the American middle class
I have to say I think the only job that
Joe Biden has ever fought for that was
an American job was for hunter Biden but
that being said do you think that
technically counts because that was for
a Chinese company so even still with
this Sony's helping out China a good
point
okay Gidley thank you again for joining
us